oh [ __ ] greetings on podcast Ville
it's Wednesday the 12th of [ __ ]
February up with Joey here the church is
brought to you by butcher box let me
tell you something what's the best night
of the week steak night that's what
night it is I got a box I got two boxes
from butcher box okay salmon the beef my
wife made the beef stroganoff it'll make
you [ __ ] little [ __ ] [ __ ] and jump
up and down that's how good it was
with butcher box you get the best
quality steaks delivery right to your
door
butcher box is it cuz it's subscription
service that sends you nine to eleven
pounds of high-quality humanely raised
meat every month that's enough to cover
you for 24 meals and butcher box is
affordable each meal breaks down to
about six dollars you can't do better
than that unless you eat and lizzard me
with the [ __ ] with the german jewish
tank over here they ship it frozen and
vacuum seal serve it arrives at your
door fresh as a [ __ ] daisy do me a
favor right now butcher box has a
special offer for free wings for like
the life of yours description let's do
what i'm sayin to you to rip free wings
for the life of your subscription that's
three pounds of wings and every box
forever plus you get twenty bucks off
your first box and free shipping in the
lower 48 just go to butcher box comm
slash Church CH you are CH or use promo
code Church at checkout
that's butcher box listen you will not
be sorry the meat was [ __ ] superb
superb I was blown the [ __ ] away
butcher box.com slash Church use promo
code churches check out butcher box the
way meat should be the church wants to
welcome Gabriel places what's happening
Gabriel what's up Papa ah thank you for
the tacos thank you for coming thank you
love cheesy goodness an ethical no that
was like six points
watch the points so you were talking in
the car on the way up here that I was
telling you I was just starting to tell
you that one night I go on Twitter and
I'm minding my own business and I see
that fluffy the nicest guy in the world
puts up
hi guys got the weekend off you know
gonna chill with my dog I just went this
chick-fil-a this stock up for some day
is something and I and I look at that
tweet Michael cuz somebody had come up
to me like a week earlier and sick of it
they said to me you know Burbank has a
new chick-fil-a and then the same
sentence they go but it's not cool to
eat there I was like no wasn't quiet
yeah I did not I did not know okay but I
heard it wasn't him to eat them hipsters
don't eat there a couple white people a
boycott of it but there's lines out the
door it doesn't matter that's why people
that's why they do that okay when you
boycott something you just giving it
more [ __ ] business
okay remember one day boy are you too
young when they boycotted dice he
welcomed p1 from Madison Square Garden
for you you bet you ban him from MTV and
exactly he's selling us all not
everything so it's a weed psychology to
it you know when the guy from the south
picks snorted the coke and he died the
next day everybody had cocaine that
killed Lenny bias everybody wanted the
cocaine that kill any buyers it just
killed the [ __ ] but you are the
nicest sweetest guy in the world
G rated comedy you do like a [ __ ] five
or thirty in the afternoon for
grandmothers and I included a photo of
my dog basically I was gonna I was gonna
go get my little nugget some nuggets and
yes I was out knowing I had posted a you
know at chick-fil-a cuz here's my thing
as anytime I'm eating somewhere I'm
doing something it's organic I love to
put the the handle so in case the
company does see if they know that I'm a
legit
fan of their product or whatever it is
and I'm not asking for anything but hey
should they send some free gift cards
I'm not gonna say no to it you know I've
gotten some amazing sponsorship by just
being you know real with
something if I'm a fan of something I
let people know and so yeah I posted a
picture of my little chihuahua and I'm
gonna get the little nugget some nugget
some chick-fil-a and next thing you know
I even saw [ __ ] that said I'm
not following you know you see these
away and Austin sir I had no I
why would I intentionally try to destroy
myself by putting something up I did not
know I honestly I tell people I'm more
hungry than woke yeah okay I am more
hungry than woke I'm sorry I'm not his
hip to everything and I did not know I
know now you got static for about I got
day yeah it was bad it was it was bad
I'm like oh my god I wrote a tweet about
suck in the end kind of miss Obama's
[ __ ] and nobody said nothing like
people just froze I was waiting for
Twitter just to shut it down oh and
nobody said nothing you know like and
it's just so weird what you could say
and what you can't say anymore and so I
just I couldn't I could not believe it
messed me up so bad because I'm thinking
to myself really it is it that bad is
bad you know and I watched someone like
like Chappelle who I think is a comedy
genius and then he'll go up there and
some of the things he talks about a very
controversial and clearly rubbed people
the wrong way but yet still selling out
he just want a Grammy before that he won
some other Peabody I forget what a
warden or yes so really he can get away
with you know pushing the envelope to
the next level but I put an innocent
tweet or I'm a fat dude talking about
chicken nuggets I think you know where
my mind was that and and I was the I was
getting people saying yeah we're gonna
boycott your show people saying how
could you we've got more of you than
this not do you know the reason behind
all I know now what is like what do you
know that I guess chick-fil-a was paying
they were they were donating money to
organizations that were against you know
gay the gay community there was you know
that they were supporting wow what is it
to try to keep them try to
straighten up a way that they think you
know supposedly I don't know there were
they were donating money to choose
something that was against the game you
don't want to claim to know that I know
exactly what I know it wasn't good I
know it wasn't good but do you think
that it's on social media because I
think like social media they just
they're not really angry but they're
just there and they because when
Chappell does on stage they have to like
actually get onto Twitter but if they're
already on Twitter leaving is just fake
anger they're not really mad at you like
if they saw you at chick-fil-a they
probably happened to see you I you know
what I've never been at a chick-fil-a
and had somebody be upset with me if
anything they'd offered to buy my my
meal which i think is cool it's it's one
of those things where I I did not know
and like I said I wasn't trying to stir
anything up but I think a lot of times
sometimes you know people want attention
and I think going after someone is
probably the easiest way I went to my
wife my wife is white so I said let me
ask you a question what's the deal with
chick-fil-a and she knows everything no
wife knows everything white she's a well
number one then all their insurance
doesn't cover woman abortions and then
the to look like gay people so I wrote a
whole bit about it but the funny thing
about oh my god I was going to tell you
something I forgot see that's why you
don't smoke pot like what's a ton of
food and I never say that you know this
is nice to have you here it's good to
see you I feel like I haven't seen my
brother from Cuba and he came back after
three years I almost didn't survive our
last our last podcast what happened you
left I heard you guys went reduce me to
this cookie I think you were sponsored
or you were doing something with this
company at the time some cheap achoo I
think was it you but you and that it was
some cookie and you're like Gabriel look
at this is cookie right it's delicious
you should try some and I took the
cookie and I you know you don't I don't
just pinch the cookie and eat a piece of
the
he had me a cookie Nicole cookies going
down and I guess for whatever reason
that had a certain level of whatever in
it I hate the whole cookie right I was
fine when I left and when I got on the
five man I've never been more grateful
for traffic in my life because I I drove
about eight miles an hour the whole way
home it hit me on the five I thought you
guys stopped and got something to eat
man
no no oh no that cookie that cookie Joe
Diaz pocket I need no more cookies no no
when I got people to drive now I'm not
go over there to get tortured I'm not
gonna go with that I don't blame you but
that cookie though Wow
sounds like the so contrasting on top of
it
I don't remember hoes I just remember I
ate a whole cookie cuz it because you
guys were looking at me like I eat that
look when like like he wasn't supposed
to eat the whole cookie because you like
you knew what the future held for me we
did something and I hate that we did
Chicago and we flew back and I took my
shirt off on the flight is it wrong that
I remember you taking off your shirt a
few times this was you were sweating you
were sweating up a storm yes yes we're
on a Southwest flight yes yeah and I'm
like I'm between two all right women 65
you were sandstorm tits I had to be 380
and I that was what happened was it was
those gummy bear it was those the tongue
things ones but nobody knows that in
those days do the dosage of them there
was no dosage you just showed them black
market they could dip them in gasoline
and then what happened was when you put
them in your wallet they got stuck
together you didn't really know how many
you eat so we did KJ riddles
me you Martin you know who's ever
booking the [ __ ] festival of debt
it had to be like salmon Otis griddles
yes yes yes yes across the street from
Steak and Shake and White Castle what we
had there with like it's just a fad all
the best choices that - all the best
choices
it was take the shake next door White
Castle across the street and the hotel
kind of like a direct line there was an
old Hindu web or non kidding it when you
went to check in it was like some chick
getting [ __ ] against the wall and then
you had you went to the hotel room and
they were [ __ ] with you you want to pawn
this I got like this before bucks but if
not it was like porn slanted so you can
still hear the chicken fight like oh
spice right so we saw the way back from
KJ riddles we all took the early flight
and I go look what am i got here so
Brett and I put them on them but in
those days in the middle
we sat opposite each other yes Southwest
Airlines had those their little lounge
seats where they'd have the seats that
faced one another in the front and in
the back they'd have those two those two
sections so we took it over and all the
semester the sweating profusely the
plane some [ __ ] it was it was scary any
brought him some towels how early into
the flight do you take your shirt off
and there were two women who sit next to
me
likes to remember the look on their face
a fortune being women never [ __ ] going
he's back yeah
I've never [ __ ] doggystyle okay with
three guys total between the two of them
you could tell that one was reading a
Bible like they never do the doggy style
she never sniffed his nutsack they put
it through a sheet with a hole and I sat
in the middle and took my shirt off
he'll never forget at one time just like
drying off with a towel like this is the
beginning of edibles I'm drying off with
a towel and I could feel go moisture on
my nipple you were shiny
he was shiny and you were and you don't
really drink or do that much Gabriel so
he wants completely so we gotta figure
at that time no I wasn't nothing I
didn't start drinking until I got was
what 24 25 Wow so what is it like being
on the road with something like that
what the time Mike you know I didn't
know what he was going no idea you know
he sweats you know I'm a big guy I sweat
I'm just like he's been doing it longer
and this is maybe his air vent doesn't
work I don't know I mean we were poor I
know I don't for a fact I was up like
I'm never getting to the airport that
day I'm late and and at the time I must
have been about twenty thirty twenty
eighteen years room my ears were still
ringing from the cocaine Wow like my
ears were still ringing I'm like man and
I was trying to keep it together in
front of you guys like if anybody else
would have looked at me I didn't know me
they would have gone I he's just tired
but my balls were on fire I knew that
people know I wish I was on the tail end
of the juice yeah that's if it would
happen today I'd be like no that's
coronavirus yeah Michael some go on I
was [ __ ] up at the airport to bounce
things off I found these them [ __ ] up
on the plane between axes you know I
found shirts of mine from my cocaine
days when I moved from Hollywood to the
valley I found a bunch of long-sleeve
white shirts because I was so big I had
a wedding long sleeve long like so I
would get like a three XL Tee tee next
I would only buy clothes in Texas
because in LA they don't have clothes
with faculty you gotta go all the way up
to founder Canyon and one of our chances
are going to come to here I'm saying or
the fat man store on Wilshire where they
charge $84 for a handkerchief that was
during the time when I want to say you
were trying to put me in touch with that
big daddy company cuz you were getting
all your clothes for yesterday Ralphie
yeah it was a big daddy run big daddy
run you know and I was I was on a big
cocaine run I just stopped buying
clothes
I just stopped wearing clay Gabe you're
always wearing jumpsuits always you
always had those ball would they look so
cool because in those days it was so
Soprano I went to so many mafia
auditions for commercials and videos and
promos that how all I wore was sweat
suits
I had a black suit that I bought that
Josh wolf bought me oh wow three suits
for 200 hours with two pairs shoes right
on Hollywood Boulevard they're still
there up the block from Joe's Hollywood
suit outlet you get three suits three
shirts three-week size belts belts socks
and a pair of shoes for $299 just make
sure nobody lights a match the flames
like a [ __ ] with the carnivorous virus
that's the video you should make it well
going into Hanoi suit suit outlet right
Dollywood suit outlet just go so did you
ever figure out the the amount that you
were supposed to actually eat of what of
those Listerine things like one little
one I think I ain't like there was three
in there clearly yeah three before they
thought one time
tell you that was me on that five
freeway coming back this had to be about
seven years ago me and Lee had just
started doing the podcast and I had one
of the last we sipped of Miami Coconut
Grove improv it was one of the laughs
yes and I don't know what the [ __ ] I had
a delta flight time a little six with
the tropical birds you [ __ ] on the wall
when you go on in Miami or Suns market
it's the most racist [ __ ] terminal in
LAX
you go in there yeah no it's not even
Cuba like they treat you like you're
[ __ ] what's those people that sell
them guns the Sandinistas they treat you
like you're a silent eastern they're the
[ __ ] it's horrible
like you walk through the white part of
the [ __ ] Delta thing mm-hmm but then
they have the South American wing and
Wallsend the wharf turn yellow and they
go like palm trees and the [ __ ] and
you're like this is racist [ __ ] did they
have everybody talking Spanish and they
got salsa music playing these are people
that added for salvador nicaragua all
those third world nations and [ __ ] like
that so Miami's in that terminal so I
flew out of that terminal on a red-eye
and I had I upgraded in the first class
I'm Delta they upgraded me to one on the
inside so I was in row one on the inside
window in the window and I start Bob and
[ __ ] animals before in the on the car
ride down there I start popping that it
was like I get on the flight and it's
the nicest gay guy in the world
that's next thing he's like oh my god
you go into Miami it's gonna be so much
fun and I'm like I know bah bah bah he
passes out all of a sudden I had a
search cinnamons search you're not
supposed to eat the whole roll of
cinnamon I ate the whole thing like I
just I lead them and the cinnamon
triggered the THC and I had jeans on I
just thought of sweat
I started sweating to the point that I
took off my shirt thank God leopard
things on his eyeballs and I'm sweating
up a storm gate and I got the blanket
around my fat stuff like I'm not sure
not and all that all the whole cabin is
sleeping but there was like one little
light that shined right I like my
[ __ ] center of my chest and every
time the stewardess would walk by she
look at me she wouldn't I'm sorry I'm
lying to you she wouldn't even look at
me guys thought I was sweating so much
when I got my luggage I went to pull up
my pants and the rim around my jeans
would drenched with sweat
that's how much I sweat on that [ __ ]
fly from th I can't imagine take I guess
a big guys like that's the last thing I
want to do is take my shirt off in
public
oh yeah I can't imagine you have that we
tend to heal is there okay versus hi
it's totally different you know no
matter how high I was I wasn't getting
naked no matter what but drunk that's
different
I got so drunk in Puerto Rico I went up
on a mechanical bull
you can find that photo online by the
way I let people know I was like 19
madea's that is the Puerto Rican beer
good times what else is going on in your
world well let's see we just finished
wrapping the show we finish wrapping the
show last season to eduation thank you
you happy doing it you know what let me
tell you something B people the people
is what I'm gonna miss I'm not gonna
miss the hours I'm not gonna miss the
three hours a day in traffic I'm not
gonna miss the you know a little bit of
sleep that I was getting it's a lot of
work a lot of work doing that show TV
show TV shows a lot of work it takes up
all your time and energy and I love the
finished product and like I said I love
the people if the people were horrible
it'd have been a different thing I'd
have been like I'm out you got a nice
little cast every way you like you mean
kid I grew up with him with Oscar Nunez
yeah yeah
say that T no he were talking about you
the other night no I guess the same
school or something he's he's from a
town called Union City you see the
Irishman yeah but Tony Pro is wrong but
Tony pros office as well he's some
meetings city I hung with his brother I
was you know the older kids near
neighbourhood who you idolized I
idolized his brothers brother's name was
none zo and up the corner from my
mother's bother it was a hot dog stand
the best separate hot dogs just ride out
of New York City but in New Jersey and I
would go up to everything at two or
three of them annunzio would take
numbers and hang out with the guy all
day so why you got a hot dog I'm not
zero
give me 204 206 whatever yeah it was
another zero or the guy would do one
book there but I knew none zo but me and
him were kids together so he went I
can't miss in high school and I went to
North Bergen which is to complete the
different districts but since I was
Cuban my mother had a bar in that
neighborhood so I knew all those kids so
that's how long we go back Wow
and then I bumped into him in the
audition in 98 didn't know him we were
up in Telemundo England Dale we're
reading for some Cuban show and that's
what we started talking I met him in 98
on the fly and he goes maybe you know my
older brother nuns yeah but he's just
[ __ ] yeah it's a long and that job I
got hired they paid me a thousand bucks
to shoot three days they hired me my
call time was an 8 I went to lunch at 12
and the 12th or they called me at a 5
they just I killed it in the audition
but I really wasn't what they were
looking for mmm and when as soon as I
spoke Spanish the Cubans [ __ ] freaked
they got scared of because they were
like for the nice part of Cuba and they
speak that Spain Spanish there was
really so intimidated
but one of those guys ended up being on
George Lopez's first ABC show hmm he was
the sidekick and he is Laila I was
living here I moved here and I would
walk my wife to work and then I would
walk around look I just Hollywood Park
and one day I saw him and I walked past
him and he goes hey hey excuse me do you
remember me and I made believe like I
did I go no I don't I know you're on
George Lopez I think what she had before
do you remember me
and I go no he goes I was on that show
that time would tell him we'll know he
told me the name of the show he goes and
I just want to tell you like a man then
it was not me who got you fired you
scared like four or five of the Cuban
people because he's Mexican he's really
Mexican Oscars no no kid then he ended
up on Joey's first show not this other
little Mexican guy ended up he was like
a father or an uncle or something like
that he was a regular on the show I saw
him in North Hollywood Park and he came
up to me man that was 15 I forgot all
about it I wasn't even scared that they
fired me because it paid for my after
after was 800 that so you had a pay sag
Frank 50 and afterwards 800 so whatever
it was a week later I got an after card
in the mail so it didn't really matter
mr. Grodin you think that single Derrick
man Wow I mean yeah I remember when you
were shooting the ABC show and you
called me and there was a roll there was
a roll that you were thinking but and I
kept saying I don't want to go in
because when I read it I read it black
mmm this was a role for a black guy and
I know that that was the beginning of
diversity for television I know that the
pilot didn't work out of ABC and I gonna
find anything about Gabriel he's [ __ ]
jumping up and down because it's so
weird the excitement you have when
you're selling the show and they say yes
and you get pumped up for it
you feel that yeah and after three weeks
you can't not [ __ ] take it no more
between the questions to what you could
say what you can't say what the budget
of the show is who could be on the show
can't be on the show and then you think
I can't wait to be back on the [ __ ]
Road well it's my show from A to Z and
you start comparing it like years ago
you called me for anything I would
cancel comedy show today I might cancel
economy show for an acting gig anymore
it's too much [ __ ] work and you know
I love to act you see him Roy we've
discussed mutual film
discussed I remember you I think you
called me and said I loved you and
grudge match whatever I enjoyed grudge
match even though I broke even
how can you [ __ ] break even in De
Niro movie how the [ __ ] do what that I
have to do to comedy shows just put
money in my pocket I take a loss I take
a lot when we came up the Bicycle Club
yeah what did we talk about with one day
we we can't wait till one day we're
making 28 thousand a week of the TV show
as a [ __ ] co-star where we missed all
that like everybody else oh my god you
missed it it was 60,000 the co-star for
two episodes what are you [ __ ]
talking about I'm getting 1215 episode
the co-star to be hotdog man and to be a
security guard is [ __ ] and it was like
now I love the freedom of stand-up so
much that Gabriel if you come up to me
and go excuse me the word is not like
that scripty lady like I've just grown
to hate them
especially the TV one the ones that
you've been on a bad TV show and they
come up to you like eight times to
correct you and finally you go kamiya
physical every every week and her name
on my show her name is sore Ella and
she's she's wonderful she's awesome
she's put up with me and my moods cuz
yeah you know my whole thing is if if
I'm conveying the correct message and
I'm in the line that I'm delivering
allows the actor I'm working with to
understand that it's his or her turn I
don't see the problem but of course then
they hit you with the word you know it's
got to have continuity it's got to match
up with the last scene in case I got to
cut this into this into this thing to
that scene and and I understand but yet
when they nitpick and in its in its one
word and it's like really are you
supposed to say this word first then
it's this word but you're saying both
you're still getting it right but you're
just mixing it up but it's still the
same message yeah I get annoyed I get on
your own show oh yeah yeah yeah and I'm
an EP on my show so sometimes I'll just
put my foot down do you know what just
for that lines gone I'm taking the line
on I'm giving I'm giving that line to
somebody else and I'm just gonna sit
here and watch I've done that a couple
times where I've been annoyed by a line
but for the most part though working
with Netflix worse versus working with
ABC night and day ABC I did go through
all that that you just mentioned the you
know they question everything you give
them an idea and then they hire someone
else to change your idea you know you
said all I'd like it to be like this and
God know it would work better like that
and you never want to argue or or stand
up for what your project project is
because you don't know if you're if
you're stepping on toes like me I was
always like I just want to make sure
that I don't you know I'll raise my hand
when I really want to raise it but I
figured if I did it early on I'd be
suiting myself in the foot so I allowed
someone else to control and run the way
that it went and ABC would you know I
picked certain people that I wanted to
work with and they're like well they're
okay but we think that this person would
fit better this person would fit better
and one of the one of the people that I
chose that I wanted to be a sidekick on
on my show on ABC
he killed the read he was amazing so
funny and charismatic and just he
delivered and they did not like him for
whatever reason and they gave me someone
who was much taller looked way different
he looked more of like a leading man
versus being a sidekick
and he wasn't as good did you think at
times when you work through that work
that it was like I mean we first started
Gabriel on Saturday he wasn't in the
office and the guy said we had a good
week here's your three hurdles and while
you were sitting there waiting from the
cast a check-in signing over to you you
look around the office and you saw you
saw 10 million tapes with dust on and
you're like look at these poor bastards
like remember people used to say you
send me a tape yeah Pete Mincey that's
like comics today there's I don't want
to sound like that old guy they don't
know we went through in our time like
yeah I remember sitting in the freakin
Bart Reed sitting there and there's a
pile of VHS tapes in the corner or being
in Columbus Ohio and seeing of just a
room that was dedicated to tapes and I
was happy that I got in more so through
word of mouth because I don't remember
sending out a lot of tapes but I did
have a lot of comics that were
vouch for me hey you going he can emcee
he can he can do this he can do that not
what I always worked for whatever cuz I
wasn't I was more I want the experience
I want to go out there cuz I love it you
know and and yeah I was I was using my
real job to support my comment my comedy
habit I felt at the time I wasn't making
any real money I [ __ ] hate it when
people ask me for the tape especially
after I became a regular at the store I
wouldn't send you a tape in fact you'll
copy this schedule with Paul Mooney in
front of me and go with the woman we do
talk about on it when I was trying to
prove to you and the guy who busted my
balls the most was Freddy so no kept
coming up to me in 97 going hey man that
guy in Houston really wants to hire you
but he needs a tape he was talking about
mark Babbitt
one day you know what I'm going to do
this one hunt for nine months
I will go Babbitt just give me a [ __ ]
week Joey I'm telling you leave the tape
I gotta run it by the owner you're such
a scumbag you're such a [ __ ] scumbag
I'm alright
and then he would call me again Joey I
never got your tape in the mail Joey
what's going on so finally one day I
just got a blank tape clap a resume and
a headshot I said that the Houston and a
week later he's like what are you doing
September 23rd 25th you sent him a
belaying length tape he told me he loved
it
and that's what I realize I [ __ ] hate
these [ __ ] Booker's that's when I
realize oh my god this was 1997 he told
me he loved it blank is [ __ ] and that
became my signature I would send you
blank tapes and people we loved it it
was great well it was great yeah we and
that's when I realized there was a power
thing I'll never forget people calling
me and I'm laying knowin I ain't doing
what they're gonna putting together a
show can you send us a tape let me give
you adjusting you only won one for
Canada driving what were we talking
about tape yeah well you know we need a
taper you doing stand-up grab a pen
Thursday night 10:30 The Improv Friday
at 11:45 the Comedy Store sadly temporal
it was what tape do you mean that would
really piss me off if they were local
and they wanted the tape I would force
them to come out of night I wouldn't do
business work I don't want to [ __ ] be
in your stupid show yeah I'm fine this
way the babbling said the blame thing -
[ __ ] you dog mark Babbitt
he was a club owner but he wasn't a club
owner I I had my own little run with him
too and he he still owes me about 8
grand
you know Gabriel it's what you said you
fell in love with it and you took the
ball and ran with it
you really did thinking back now like
don't get me wrong we all
running with the ball you ran behind the
right [ __ ] like it was just a path
and I saw it and then a couple TV
appearances
you know [ __ ] it just it just kept
the momentum and I think I went out with
you somewhere I saw the likability after
the show or the people talking to you
and you just you just took off like the
wild and nobody deserves it more than
you you sacrificed your life for this
thing I'm here to tell you that Gabriel
ASIS sacrificed his life for this thing
we could go into hours of detail we
won't go there
I'm sure the therapist talked to you
about that already but we sacrified you
know people understand what sacrificing
your life is when your cousin gets
married and you send the check you don't
live your life we just send checks we
don't go to weddings
we don't go to nephews birthdays we
don't do anything at the end of the day
you have to ask yourself what am I
willing to give up because it is a
sacrifice you know people say they want
they want to be there they want to be on
top they want to be the guy or the girl
whatever what are you willing to give up
that should be the question and I can
honestly say I've sacrificed everything
or sacrificed family friendships moments
that I'll never get back you know to do
what I do
i I I love the stage more than I love
myself
I've given up health the night my mom
passed away I was on a stage the day she
was buried I was doing a show that's
that's that's how much I gave up because
I needed to be onstage to function to to
not break down
you know people people ask me all the
time although you know what what should
i do how can i what are you willing to
give up and and a lot of times people
you know they are I've offered to take
comics out on the road oh you know I got
the thing with my kid has happened
okay well you know what and then ain't
and that's that's what that's what you
need to do but what are you willing to
give up you got to be fresh you dig they
live the funeral I did not attend my
mom's funeral for the simple fact that
my family does did not see me how can I
put this me going to my mom's funeral
probably would have would have ended
landed me in jail because my siblings
and I did not see eye-to-eye because
they don't understand what it is that I
do they didn't understand what I was
willing to give up in order to be in a
certain place and I still haven't spoken
to my brother since but when when it all
went down if I could take it back
honestly I realized that it was more so
me versus my siblings and I should have
I should have thought about the bigger
picture but unfortunately I was in such
a rage in such an ugly place where I
would have made a big mistake by being
there because any little thing would
have set me off I remember that night
that my brother called me up and the
conversation that we had it just I
couldn't see anything but read I
couldn't see anything but read and no
matter what he tried to say to me it
just wasn't clicking and I'd gotten a
text message from a friend of my Armando
co-ceo and he was he was there and I
remember getting that message and just
like what was I thinking like I cuz I
could have I could have been there and
when people ask me about regrets and
things that I wish I could do
differently that's that's definitely one
of them
I'm I'm an adult now where I can look
back on it and go you know what I should
have checked my pride I should have I
should have checked everything because
it wasn't about me it wasn't about my
brother it wasn't about my siblings it
was about my mom and even though we
weren't on the best of terms at that
time we were in the process of trying to
resolve things and she had gotten sick
before I got a chance to to make that
make that the case and I remember I was
I was in so much pain and I just
the only thing that could get me out of
that was to be on stage and I remember I
was in Ontario I went and did a show in
Ontario at the improv and at the end
asked for a shot and I said you guys
have no idea the the day that I'm having
right now and and someone goes what
happened I go you don't want to hear it
and then I come on it was like let me
just tell you what happened and the
whole crowd got quiet and I'm like yeah
that's that's what I'm dealing with ISM
right now and I drink a lot that night
and it was one of those things where you
know what are you willing to give up and
at that that time that's that's why I
gave up and I miss my mom dearly and I'm
sad that I I wasn't there
at the end when I had an opportunity to
be there I just don't think that I was
in the right mindset so you know you you
you work hard you wanna you want to be a
certain person you want to excel what is
it you're willing to give up and I I
gave up my family I can say that night
and I don't have a relationship with my
brother now I've barely talked to my
sisters and you know when I visit my
mom's grave it's it's it's I can't say
I'm sorry enough you know but there's
moments where you know you you you think
you're doing the right thing
and that for me is my biggest regret
because my mom would have done anything
for me I don't even busting your ass
Christmas you do how many shows do and
that's another thing to do up
Christmases I would work Christmases
because I couldn't be around my family
Joey it was that bad it's like then they
wouldn't look at me and talk to me like
a person I was I was now a thing
I was now this this personality I was
this this this this thing that just is
on TV it's and they all saw it as
something that was easy like my brother
insulted the hell out of me one night
when he's like he's he told somebody in
the house I'm funnier than him what
really and I'm like they didn't
understand and the more I tried to
explain things I just
you know it became a thing where yes I
became the guy that signed checks I
became the guy that you know can you
loan me money I got tired of loaning
money cuz nobody would ever pay it back
so I just learned to just give it you
know it's it's hard when people stop
looking at you like a person and they
just look at you like this that thing
you know at the end of the day I'm still
flesh and blood
I still feel pain I still make good
decisions bad decisions I'm a human you
know as I'm a person but when people
cannot separate the fact that you know
you're just that how did your mom feel
because I I remember the special where
your mom was in there in the baby my mom
was a big supporter she would never
laugh at my joke she was more so like
you know he's doing what he wants to do
I remember one day I brought home a
flyer I showed my mom flyer of me on the
flyer she was so happy about a freaking
flyer and I go mom I've been on TV this
flight really the flyer she goes no
miko' park I can take it to bingo and
shelters everyone knows me at McCoy's on
a flyer I'm like that was when Flyers
were the social media of the time but uh
no she was a huge supporter just that it
came to a point where even she was
having issues with what I was doing in
the amount of time I was gone and and
then she wasn't a big fan of my
girlfriend either so that became a thing
you know and it was it was hard it was
hard doing you know man I've been saying
this for the last couple years that we
went in a search to becoming a comedian
but what we ended up becoming were men
like I grew up in this [ __ ] this made me
be a man this whole [ __ ] game it
taught me a lot I learned a lot from
this game we saw people blow up and
shoot themselves in the foot
we saw Tiffany Haddish blow up we saw
people come and go you know I stopped
ever taking a ride with you from Burbank
Airport
to side on Wednesday night to a club
called Bugsy's the guy would pick you up
the guy must be Alex was like yeah
tell him this totally the size of the
bolt behind his neck put together eating
together it was a sweetheart of a guy I
don't even know if he's still around but
because I know he lost a bunch of weight
but he came to a commie store he lost
some yeah there's a everybod called big
Alex not just Alex it was big Alex he
was he was huge I remember every time I
see him he was getting out of a suburban
he was always in the front seat of
suburban and it'd take him a minute to
get out of the car it was just big tall
he's like six five huge and sweetheart
of a guy we would work at a Bugsy's on
the corner of Roger and Oracle in Tucson
Arizona and I know this because I still
have the poster I still have the poster
from when I performed there and I had
done shows with you there you and Debbie
Gutierrez I did one show there I did
another show with Rudy and Gilbert and
Joey Medina was the Booker he was the
one that set me up to go down there but
yeah one photo shows one show paid like
150
buy the plane ticket I didn't get 150 I
got 50 because they had taken my money
to split it between Rudy and Gilbert so
I got 50 and a plane ticket I didn't
care at the time because I was that was
the first time I went on the road that's
why I saved the poster because it was my
first road gig he would pick you up take
this from Mexico take you to eat that
was one thing my big Alex would take you
to eat make you feel special take you to
the hotel we go check in at the cliff
Manor in and I'm like wow the cliff
manners next to a golf course this place
it was disgusting it's disgusting now no
no and then I still remember staying
there with Darren Carter in that black
girl and the black girl [ __ ] call me
in the middle of night she's like you
gotta figure something out people trying
to break into my door and it was a whole
town and then you crossed the street
there was a combined Mexican restaurant
yes this is in Westwood yeah that was a
crappy [ __ ] you know but if you don't
know what a crack when we were doing
family that was a Tosh bar that's the
thing - that was one night in a hotel
you
to the room at four and you had three
hours them to pick you up you have no
idea you would get naked and just lay on
the bed you know they tell you to take
the sheet off the people have come on it
right you don't even give a [ __ ] you lay
on top of that thing you put HBO on you
pick your feet you got three hours the
hotel room you've been [ __ ] performing
in West Covina and all these [ __ ]
places the last two months now you're in
Tucson Arizona
oh [ __ ] I'm on fire I never saw that
place as a rat hole or Sun no Mimi that
was the greatest thing it was the
greatest thing in my world later no
[ __ ] wins they like to pick up 150
bucks
I remember hearing my name on the radio
for the first time I was in my room and
I had the radio on and I heard before II
- you know this weekend the you know
Bugsy's and I heard my name for the
first time and I screamed so loud when I
heard it all I was like that scene from
that thing you do when the kids are
running and their song is playing and I
was just like I got up at the dorm
screaming so happy how long I understand
it were you ah you gotta figure I
started April 10th of 1997 and I was on
the road July 4 was it 12 so me yeah
three months oh [ __ ] I was doing comedy
three months and I was on the road
performing in Tucson Arizona and I'm at
this hotel which for me I'd never been
on a flight I had never been in a hotel
whoa
so for me by all kinds of cherries got
popped in Tucson yeah that happened
there - I remember the first time I went
there I was with Gilbert and was Rudy
and they knew that that was my first
time on a plane and so Rudy tells me a
listen man look you're on the road III
remember Rudy and Gilbert from that show
comedy compiled it is back in the day
and salsa oh my god you know the world
yeah it was and I'm like I'm hanging out
with these two guys are you kidding me
so I just wanted it I was I was so green
and and Rudy tells me listen when the
flight attendant comes by and she offers
you soda don't make me look bad make
sure you you know you give her a good
tip make sure you give her a good tip
and if they try to you know give it back
you insist that they take it
okay we got to make sure that you know
don't make me look stupid and I'm like
no sir and I was that was that kid no
sir absolutely not I was 20 21 no I
wasn't in 21 yet I turned 21 a few days
later I was 20 years old and sure enough
here comes a flight attendant she brings
me my coke and with the ice and
everything in the napkin and I tried to
give her five bucks she goes no no sir
it's okay
oh no no no I insist she's like no sir
I'm not supposed to take the money it's
okay it's and I'm trying to put the
money on her and Rudy and Gilbert are
just they're dying I'm like what's so
fun and then I realized a ribbon me and
I'm like ah here we go here we go humbly
like did you do at the brave bull oh man
I lost count of how many times I worked
the brave bull or worked work the brave
bull or worked Commerce or worked the
Icehouse on the I don't know how many
last grand finale shows there were gonna
be at the ice house I don't know how
many the lot you know because Rudy's
always having it's the last one it's the
last one it's the farewell to the East
Side comedy jet it's over it's done
we've had an incredible run it's over
we're finished the last one this
Wednesday it's over it's done that's it
he always gave me a mess in the last you
know don't forget those flights in
Tucson and all those other shows that I
booked it emerges it's the last one when
I do the last show before I knew it was
so yeah but the brave I had so many
great memories the brave bull and me
Joey tonight
you know the VP of the bank is here and
I would go up there you go extra dirty
and I go extra [ __ ] dirty and they
would go crazy but I think the best
night I had at the brave bull the brave
bull was a bar in and now I want to say
it was San Gabriel st. Gabriel yeah and
it was Fridays and Saturdays they had
not tell exaggerated how many rooms did
they have that you do comedy there
well they had like the the main room or
or it was like a I'd say about a 600
seater where they'd have you know bands
play and stuff like that and then they
had the smaller rooms like little
annexes in there they would haul the
little bar room it was awesome I thought
have been a comedy club it would there
would have been like the the store the
main room the belly room you know what
room you were gonna be there when he
booked you like when he would call you
who are you available Friday night you
got yeah yeah and some nights you were
in the little room some nights you would
look at the orange on the wall like
there was different horns from different
Bulls
oh my gosh sheep and [ __ ] then there was
a banquet room in the back that's the
first place I showcase room
I kept call bro I I could say his father
but I still know it by heart how many
times I call the boy children back we
just spoke because he had a heart attack
what was it like for real for real yeah
I'm sorry I'm sorry I question it now
just because of him with Andrew you know
I love you to all my heart you're the
funniest man on Facebook he had a
picture in it with a our cheeseburger
and a soda and it said two days before I
had the heart attack and he was having
like a double cheeseburger so he
contacted me and it was rude Joey
promise me you'll take care yourself
then we went back and forth
they told me what happened and
ba-ba-ba-ba I haven't heard about the
benefit yet but if I know anything about
it's common you know the same like I see
the big benefit El Portal
that type of [ __ ] you know I'm saying so
but the regardless it was so weird
because he gave us 300 spots you know in
those days we were doing 45 spots a
month Gabriel yeah and they weren't they
weren't comedy clubs there were there
were rooms yeah
sorry into it how did you get the
Bicycle Club debt so you would don't
comedy three months because I remember
you had the Bicycle Club and there were
some weeks that you weren't there cuz
you were on the road I had I didn't look
at the Bicycle Club I made friends with
the food and beverage manager who had
seen me perform somewhere guys name was
Javier Sanchez still owe him $200 by the
way you know I owe him because I was
there was a month where I couldn't pay
my rent and I reached out to him and he
hooked it was come by the the bike and
he gave me 200 bucks I could pay my rent
and it was one of those things where
just I kept struggling to lick like I'll
pay soon as I got the money I'll pay I
said and it was just one of those things
where I get took awhile for me to catch
up and eventually I lost the room and
lost contact with him but uh he was the
one that offered me the room because you
think you can set up this room and I
remember had just got a computer and a
printer and I printed out my own tickets
and I was giving out tickets and
inviting people and that's when I met uh
my first fan her name's Monica Sanchez I
just saw her a couple nights ago her
husband Tony they were always coming to
the room and they would bring every week
they'd come back to see me do those same
15 minutes and they would bring people
and then those people would bring people
and then it just became one of those
things where you know it was they would
they grew my audience in that area and I
would do shows for Monica and her garage
Oh one of the first new year shows that
I did I was in her garage performing but
that's how I got the bike I mean I got
the you know Javier Sanchez saw me
perform somewhere and then he goes hey
man what do you think and little by
little comics would come out and do the
show and he gave me a small budget till
it don't work but hey you got a free
meal you got made a couple bucks and you
know free drinks and you had
back on Friday and get paid you had to
drive back home fry did all your pain
I'll never forget going into traffic
like at 4:30 come on let me go to a
bicycle club oh my god I didn't get home
till 8 o'clock at night on a Friday
night to go pick up 35 [ __ ] dollars if
I would have known I would have left it
there for the [ __ ] 35 hours I could
have borrowed $25 I was few were you
clean back then uh you know what I was
when I first started doing stand-up in
97 I was cussing a lot it was a it was a
nervous cus I was just throwing f-bombs
just to throw them just to fill fill
space I felt like you know four seconds
without a lap was was too long so I
needed to fill it you know so you know
you know f that's F that's it's a v8
whatever and of all people join Medina
was the one that pulled me aside and it
goes hey listen man you're really funny
you're you're likable you don't need to
cuss and it's crazy coming from joy
because joy joy causes a lot in his act
he goes you don't need to cuss if you
work clean now you'll never have to edit
your set when you get an opportunity
like a Tonight Show or something you'll
just be ready you don't have to edit
you'll be ready and that's probably the
greatest advice I ever got from a comic
was telling me to work clean I'll cuss
in my show now but I don't it's not a
lot it's a little bit here and there but
definitely that helped out so much in
the beginning cuz I was able to go
anywhere I was able to perform it you
know at noon it went for a kids show or
I could go and do two shows at night you
know I could go perform at a church I
could go perform a corporate function
I'm good I was doing a lot of college
work because of that so for me that's
that's what helped to grow everything
was like hey he's he's safe I avoided
you know people tell me well like okay
well what what do you think is a you
know big contributing factor to why
you're where you're at so it's not
always what you say it's what you don't
say I don't talk politics I don't talk
religion and I don't talk sports because
all three of those things will ruffle
feathers and then you divide your
audience and so some people say well
you're not as edgy you're not as this
you're not as that well yeah but the
place is full yeah you know oh yeah I
tell people I have an opinion that's why
I don't I don't do I don't can't do a
podcast cuz I don't have a strong enough
opinion to put out there
you know I keep my my show safe for a
reason I want people to enjoy themselves
and not have to think I don't want to
make people think I'd rather just
entertain that's what I chose to do just
to entertain if I have an opinion you
buy me a drink
you might hear me say some [ __ ] but yeah
I don't I put away from the stage you
know when I was coming up I opened up
for a lot of guys and there was two
people who stood out I opened up for in
those days one was rich Jenny watching
people easy of his show because there's
a feature act that's what I would watch
the people leaving the show their
reaction rich Jenny got the best
reaction because he was just a pure
comics stand-up and the second best
reaction this is 97 to 2000 1 or 2 the
second best reaction was Pablo's people
he didn't curse he made the noises he
jumped up and down
[Laughter]
let me tell you something I was living
in Seattle I did not think I was too
[ __ ] I was a regular comic I was dirty
I knew limitations I was starting to
find who the [ __ ] I was I had to get
angry I was living in an office and one
that I went down there frustrated and I
realized what I had and I go I gotta
work off that angle get him saying we
gotta just I figured I was gonna bus
Pablo and I worked off an angle and I
started opening for people when I
watched I'm opening up for Stanhope I
don't know what not opening up first at
home watching Stanhope I hadn't met him
I opened up for him early in Boulder
when I was the house emcee but later on
after he was in San Francisco I'm going
to see him to a full house and by the
time he got on stage it's 75 people I
walked out the people who stayed were on
the [ __ ] floor I know
laughter the people left there ran the
[ __ ] out of that in my mind I never saw
the benefit of that even though I'm a
dirty comic like I remember when I got
the longest yard
I had a little bit of heat I went out of
the road
I remember going out walking through the
hallway and people would see me and
their reaction towards and they thought
I was gonna have him saying his friends
I was gonna jump up and down and [ __ ]
play the [ __ ] fiddle although
whatever the [ __ ] and I'm up there
talking about snorting coke with my cat
and [ __ ] and at the end they would walk
out and Gabriel they wouldn't even touch
me like I would see them walk out like
you know and I got to see the reactions
of people then I opened for you
somewhere and I saw the same say that
you had beaten out Pablo now it was you
and rich Jenni that one people left your
shows it was like they just left
Disneyland you don't say I'm like they
had that look on their face when people
leave my shows guys look happy yeah
let's go home Lee and monkey in the
chicks like Jesus [ __ ] Christ and then
I put a [ __ ] [ __ ] that likes a fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know this is the
truth and that's the thing I always
admired about you that it was Richard
Jane and Pablo and then you just moved
into that slot and it didn't matter
would it with you Latins black Asian you
know I'm saying I'm talking as a
comedian watching people leave a show as
a feature act you know like in Miami I
want you know people run out of Paul
Mooney show oh yeah
black people would walk out he would you
know [ __ ] hand wore them to death as
they were walking there yeah some people
that's cool I know people that loved
walking rooms when I was coming up in
Seattle there was two comedians that
they live for that [ __ ] game to go out
there with the worst joke they can say
that many people get up and go [ __ ] you
instead
I never liked that hmm when I go on
stage I think people see my heart and
they let me get away with her when I get
away with you're following me but they
know it's not really who the [ __ ] I am
and honor I can't go home and spit out
my waters back she wouldn't go for that
[ __ ] you know saying but when people go
see a Gabriel AC show when you seen him
on the way out date I saw footage and it
was like what more when Pablo went back
to the village to pick up a [ __ ]
suitcase and narcos he went back to the
village and he came out all the [ __ ]
time being surrounded with Mina it
stopped Bob look that was you they
surrounded you had all these Spanish
people around you know it's scene I'm
talking about right yeah well he told
the kid I was the guy who had the
taxicab Le Monde limo will he love me
Mom
he just started giving our [ __ ]
hunches Mina it's Pablo
I know 17a Pablo god bless you Pablo
that this was you without anything at
200 our bills it was that seemed like I
don't know where I saw the footage maybe
there's only his specials something I
saw them reacting to you afterward there
was like he's like wasn't Pablo Escobar
without the co think about Pablo had a
show up with coke and a box on our bill
for people treat them like that they
come they treat you like you know it's
unbelievable and you handle it and then
I see you on Twitter and I see how
people you know when you get on Twitter
you like I'm gonna be on Twitter for the
next 45 minutes ask me whatever the [ __ ]
you want
you know what are you gonna eat for
breakfast you tell me to tacos when I
get to Houston you know your favorite
taco spot [ __ ] oh it's just a really
neat thing you know over the [ __ ]
holidays I'm looking at Twitter and I
see these pictures you sold out like
staples
Anaheim they canceled the duck game
because you showed up
this cancellous of the Gabriel once
before tonight
the [ __ ] chance of the way but
[ __ ] they cancer the duck game I
think Christmas Day you wanted to each
and broth you know it's just it's just
remarkable what you do and I'm happy
that you're right you're at me we're
talking about 20 years ago getting 50
bucks going to Tucson Arizona and with
you like me the love is still there for
it
I still [ __ ] love it I still [ __ ]
love it yes all for this whole season to
like you know what are you gonna what
are you gonna do when the the show's
over I'm gonna go home we'll go back to
do my badge and do what I love to do I'm
excited that I get to go back on the
road this week how many we see you shoot
the show see do - uh let's see what the
hiatus isn't everything was probably 15
weeks 15 weeks of time that I was not
out like I'd still do dates on the
weekends if I could pop in somewhere to
go casino or go do you know yeah in
between that I still did that staples
Honda run but I had booked that up way
before the show was set so those those
dates were already set in stone so I
made sure that they were just to go from
that mindset to that mindset that to me
would crush me I don't like doing it no
more I gotta go up in New York and
shooting March I would love you know
it's New York
I'm going in for to New Year I gotta be
there for eight days and how to shoot
three I don't know what days I'm gonna
shoot I love to work but I know
somewhere along the line there we go
we need you that thing then I got a call
lemonade on my act and saying I gotta
get somebody so I know better you know
saying but be sit between you and I I
really don't want to do tell me if I'm
doing this movie I'm doing this for me
you gotta be you got to do one project
and then you can do yeah you know what
if I got to a night so often around hug
water dangerous on the Apple work on the
Upper East Side any people in the
audience
and I'll just work out the back of the
notebook to [ __ ] that one who leave me
[ __ ] around and names mail I take it
back that [ __ ] I have one line that I
use
I got a Dangerfield I don't book no
dates I don't like getting confused
never mind the club you go from a set to
the Staples Center I'd have a heart
attack I have a [ __ ] panic attack and
you know what for me I on the set than I
do and and and you know doing a show you
tape live to write no we don't tape life
we don't tape live uh all those pictures
I saw were like a little audience kids
come into this Oh No we tape in front of
a live studio audience yes yes yes I
thought you meant live like the Connors
did that episode was live no no I'm
never doing nothing nothing live to tape
nothing like that anyways but yeah we
would shoot the show live in front of an
audience on Thursday and then Wednesdays
were pre shoots and then of course
rehearses rehearsals and stuff during
the week and then Friday was a table
read there's a other I'm a two year
comic and there's a lot of young comics
I know that listen to this what is it
like going from fifty people at the
bicycle casino to 20,000 people well
what does it feel the same you see it
feels the same it's a it's a different
feeling altogether because it's like
performing in front of those 50 people
at the bicycle club I think honestly I
think I tried harder I tried harder to
perform then then I do now I go in with
a different mindset because it's like I
think I had a different energy I was so
afraid of having any dead space any dead
air for me like you know well they're
not laughing I got hurt but move quick
so my speed is very different in front
of Staples it's go eat you got to slow
it down you got to let them laugh and
then take it in and then you you hear
come back to you and then you can go if
you try to perform at the same speed
you're gonna step all over your laughs
in that kind of a in that size
environment
I love clubs I mean I did the I did the
the two Big Show's Honda Staples and
then I booked myself at Irvine and on
and at Brea that Sunday because I wanted
to I wanted to join myself I enjoy the
clubs more I can I don't
no pressure there I get to have fun and
just I can see the whole audience and
and I can do Q&A I can take pictures
like I can't do that the bigger ones do
you remember we started comedy there
were guys that did stand-up got kind of
good they got a TV show and they stopped
doing comedy and then they did five
years my TV show and I never hear from
them again it used to be a comic so I
was always television was a means to the
to the end not anymore
the new breed that came in after that
was like [ __ ] you what stand-ups to the
end you know I'm I Bobby Lee you know
Bobby Lee's been on what 22 [ __ ]
shows he still has that what 9:45
slaughter but Comedy Store every night
yeah you know he's got the number three
slot every night Bobby Lee's built went
through somebody's a man how many is a
man TV that Bobby Lee though he's always
working he's always working you know
he's the voice of this the voice of that
I mean it's it's [ __ ] ridiculous
really and then because of the times do
it because of the times - I mean people
can become stars without without
Hollywood you don't need a sitcom
anymore you don't need a hit movie
anymore you know you just you got to go
viral I remember passing out flyers I
remember having to talk to people and
hey have you come out of a buy a plate
of rice at the bicycle club and and I'll
introduce you to such and such a person
just bring a couple people with you like
I used to negotiate with people to come
out and see me perform and there was no
social there was no Twitter no Instagram
Facebook that's why I give a lot of
credit to to Dane Dane Cook is the one
that opened my eyes to that whole social
media thing and when I saw that I mean
people could hate all they want but man
he took something and he ran with it
and and made millions and performed in
arenas all across the country and it was
just like it was inspiring to watch
somebody grab lightning in a bottle
because that's what he did and I said I
got to get in on this somehow and and by
the time I jumped on the myspace wagon
and got my followers there he was ahead
already moved on to Facebook and
built another 5 million following right
there and I'm too late I got it I was
always trying to play catch-up and
finally once I got into the mix and then
got into YouTube that's that's when
things started taking off when I was
able to work outside of the US was when
YouTube and Facebook took me there I'm
having a conversation with you and
somebody saw you on Facebook and India
some on some country and they brought
you out then you talked about performing
out there in India yeah that somebody
[ __ ] saw you on YouTube and when they
picked you up the Gotcha was a
struggling comedian too that they had
started watching comedy comedy because
of watching you and all that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] India he performs a son what was
the store what the [ __ ] out well um when
when Facebook start I'm sorry when not
YouTube started happening people weren't
sure exactly what to do with it you know
like okay so I can post my own videos
like well how does it work you know
nobody knew what the [ __ ] algorithm
was what you know subscribe it's like
well what is this is am I gonna pay for
this is it
you know how does it work and I was
lucky that I was just too lazy to call
people out that would take my video
content and post it as their own so I
would have I would have people that
would take these you know clips that I
did on Comedy Central and they would
post them and you know usually they say
oh no you you you click a button to try
to report them for for posting your
continent I never did that I actually
started doing the opposite because I
figured they're promoting me I would
tell people post all the videos you can
all the links you want I was doing the
opposite of what everybody else was
doing everybody thought that all they're
taking from me and I'm like I looked at
it like marketing I'm paying for
marketing so let them promote me let
them push me instead of fighting it like
when the Metallica was fighting Napster
and all them because other the posting
or posting our stuff up there and they
had good reason it's freaking Metallica
but for a regular Joe that didn't have a
following that was the best way to build
it and
YouTube had many youtube stars that were
just it was like 10 10 people that ran
YouTube that were like the the youtubers
of the time and I was introduced to a
YouTube star named raywilliamjohnson
by one of my guys at the time named
Lance Patrick he put me in contact
contact with him and he had this show
called equals 3 and every week he post
all these funny videos it was it was the
tosh point-o of youtube and actually
tosh point-o came out after that so i
meant you to say that that was the you
know that that show came from that show
and raywilliamjohnson had something like
10 million subscribers on youtube and he
allowed me to guest host a half dozen
times and every time I'd guess host I
would have another hundred thousand
followers from one appearance I was
getting more heat from doing YouTube
shows than I did from doing it Tonight
Show from doing a Letterman from doing a
Late Late Show from being having a
half-hour special so I think I was able
to capitalize by embracing that and once
I started posting my own content and
doing everything that's when I started
having followers so I get messages from
Yugoslavia from Romania and I like I'm a
big fan of yours how come you don't come
out here and that's what built up my
following because Comedy Central doesn't
play outside of the states I never did a
deal with HBO and then once Netflix
happen who you know it was one of those
things where I ran with it and I thought
you want social media you Aguila know
you have a whole big production and you
tape your shows now do you ever put that
out or is that just for the screens at
the show what do you mean tape it
because I see you behind like they have
a whole you whole production room with
like different cameras I can see I mean
maybe I'm wrong at the studio
oh no no when you're out what are you
doing the shows when you're doing live
shows like the reason we have cameras at
the shows is because we have the giant
screens right and we have to have
cameras in there so that they can post
the the images you don't put that stuff
out no no unless it's a special you know
I'll record audio record the shows just
so I can go back if I said something
that I thought was funny I can go back
and remember how I said it so I can you
know do it the next night or or work on
my material that way
but yeah social media is just it allowed
people to not have to have a sitcom like
I said to work on a show it's a it's a
loss financially but I know that it's
gonna I you do it now so that you can
stay in the mix so you can be relevant
so you can have a reason to get an
interview on a KTLA in the morning I've
cuz he's got a show I want I want people
to respect comedy the same way they
respect you know actors and rock stars
cuz I think the numbers are there I
think the numbers are there you know
Kevin Hart is a big influence I don't
strive to be as big as Kevin Hart
because I know he has the schedule
breathing he's got a schedule going to
the bathroom and I I need some freedom
but he's in he's an animal that's what
it takes some time you know listen the
guys in the gym at four o'clock in the
morning yeah I'm just going to bed at 4
a.m. yeah no it's a different a he goes
to bed at 10:00 don't he well no I like
I said he's in the gym at 4:00 so I
don't know what time he goes asleep so a
Marquis warbirds routine yeah
that's insane when he's home he goes to
both 9:10 you know there's someone yet
when you have to look that good this is
what needs to be done when you get if
you wanna make 7 million dollars a
[ __ ] movie that's what needs to be
done to make their discipline sacrifice
to be done you have to change if you
really [ __ ] serious mm-hm
you know there's a guy coming behind you
that guys breathing down your neck you
know I'm saying mm-hmm that young guy
you know I Brad Pitt still got it but
there's a young Brad Pitt right around
the [ __ ] corner yeah breakfast just
waiting to convert into Clooney oh okay
he was always Robert ready
he was always dead a replace Robert
Redford
Robert Redford [ __ ] was right there
the distinction I'm a referee was
slinging dick well when I was a kid
every woman wanted to suck Robert
Redford
but then [ __ ] Robin referee got a
little hold his hand cluttered shaking
his [ __ ] and then showed up wrap it with
the long hand without one movie and it
was all over but the shouting
it's [ __ ] craziness but no the way I
see your growth it was a constant growth
Gabriel and it was one thing that went
into the other that one into the other
because of the work you were doing it
just I didn't say no you say well okay I
didn't I started saying no recently but
I mean any time an opportunity was
presented I'm like I'm all over it okay
I'm man I'm down when let's go I was
doing 47 weeks out of the year 47 I was
working my ass off whatever gig it was I
was down what is your status right now
are you a dick slightly nice I've been
single now for uh you know a couple
years now how old is you say my son is
22 you still folks a quit yeah actually
he's uh he he was I got him a job
working as a working stage crew he was
it was a you know working at a theater
behind the scenes it was a stagehand he
did that for about a year and uh you
know nice I got him a job on the road so
he's happy and we have such a great
relationship we it's not just us passing
each other in the living room now it's
like we go out of our way to spend time
together
and he's been awesome brother I've seen
you grow up how [ __ ] crazy is that
yeah well we did hey look you you knew
me when I had hair look at this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's not a flattop not just you know I
stood I've been going to Bugsy's with
you and you had the car and we drove we
landed in Burbank and you dropped me off
maybe six blocks from here on the other
side of that [ __ ] Park you dropped me
off
mm-hmm and I don't know what that per
car was whose car was I don't know if it
was Ivan
I don't know who the [ __ ] it was I
didn't know I was going home like you
didn't know when you were getting home
you got 150 dollars it was 50 for the
coke put you a hundred right there you
had a tip the bartender 20 and ain't
breakfast that was ten
now you down to sixty [ __ ] dollars
you're coming home with sixty [ __ ]
dollars you went all the way to Tucson
Arizona he had a burrito you [ __ ]
what at one time I went with Larry Omaha
and this is the funniest thing I ever
saw comics dead if there was because the
place would get 90 people right Bugsy's
uh you know what back then I just I
remember 75 to me it looked like a
thousand people worked out those days
compared to the Bicycle Club yeah but
half in the show they would put like a
deejay would come out yeah and there was
dancing there was dancing and I remember
him going up to like eight women in a
row and like him we get a shot down in
flames like eight times in a row and
finally like this little ugly 71 was I
don't know
and she started I was sitting there
watch this the whole thing I saw the
creepiest things go down at that place
but here we are brother 20 years later
and I'm happy you took the time that
came up and say hello you know I miss
you and it's great to see all your
success and I always break your balls on
Twitter oh yeah there's not a lot of
people that I can say I'd go back with
that I still have a good relationship
with ya know cuz with time and with
growth and change some people don't
handle it well some people don't handle
change well some people don't handle
growth well some people can only grow
and when I say grow I don't you know
there's a way whether it's work ethics
or whether it's you know you said
earlier about becoming a man like you
know what did it take I mean I there was
a lot of pain want to get to a certain
place and and some people will stay that
way and not learn from it and there's
some people that they can grow past it I
feel like I've gone through so much over
the years and I appreciate the fact that
you've always been
you've always been you and if there was
anything if I had ever did anything that
uh it required calling out you you were
the first to do it and there was always
a respect that you know
hey uncle uncle Joey said and you know
like my daddy would call me up a man
could Joe has some question here we go
and I get nervous because I'm like I saw
you very much like a parental figure
where I was like man what what did I do
I got asked Martinez like I don't know
man but he wants to know yeah alright
here we go alright so that there's
always been that respect and that love
there for you know I'll never forget
that one night we were at the comedy
store and it was it was it was
Maryland's you know like funeral and and
it Jeff Valdez went up there and I'm
like oh my god and I witnessed uh yeah I
saw I saw the sight of Joey that I never
wanted to be in front of I saw I saw
those flames directed at someone and it
wasn't me and I was I was never more
happy that that was never on your bad
side
I'm trying to write a joke right now
comparing awake to Hollywood like I saw
my mother get buried and I went to this
wake in Cuban waste of five days four
days [ __ ] long
you know the harm has to pop up of all a
barrier they swear to god you suck he's
got a move before they bury him so I saw
these people come into this wake and
everybody told me if I ever needed
anything to call and a month later when
I call him the phone was disconnected
mmm you know so I've always had a big
powerful wakes but I just don't [ __ ]
light so I walk in there and they see
there's a backstory to the Jeff out this
think you know how he tortured me in
Maryland for years and that thing that
he did to me with the Latino life
festival I never ever forgot that
because he made me showcase like a
donkey five times clean and then he said
you know and make it to the festival but
then he did a midnight blue show
anything nasty to do the dirty show and
I saw Matt that he came to the store on
purpose that Monday like wait to rub it
in my face and I was like that's a
declaration of war but I'll save that
for later down the road that's how crazy
I am so this is 98 and I say that as a
declaration of war that showed back up
in 2007 like I always knew I was gonna
stab him one way or another I'm looking
at you in the face and I'm telling you
that that whole thing Wow how to
describe to comedians what a felt like
it was a time in my life where I
couldn't find an agent I was booking
[ __ ] I booked the CBS pilot
I booked basketball and I had booked
some mouse everybody was gonna have
agents everybody was going to Montreal
everybody was getting something Here I
am stuck at the store following for
morning every night and I didn't really
see it for what it was do you I'm saying
done so here I am living my life I never
bothered the Latin community in 2000 in
1996 they called me in Seattle and flew
me down and put me in a hotel [ __ ]
and took me to a lie factory made me go
up number six behind greg Giraldo and
[ __ ] mom this is Impala was a [ __ ]
Buick House this is from Pablo was doing
Seinfeld in Spanish and once I saw that
my insides broken we got him deserved to
be down here so I went up they put me up
my number [ __ ] - I'm a Cuban 9 and
all Mexican rule I get [ __ ] buried I
get off stage there was one person who
came up to me and gave me ugh Marilyn
Martinez came up to me she was that's
the funniest thing I ever saw in my life
these steps just don't [ __ ] get it a
nun and [ __ ] down they have a broom up
their [ __ ] [ __ ]
she would just go off and delight this
thing that's how I met Marilyn Martinez
was after bombing my first time ever in
LA and getting off the stage and her
going off and taking me outside and
telling me to move here but I should be
on the next plane down here that they're
looking for guys like me and I remember
taking her number and I went back to
Seattle kept in touch of mouth and then
I got the deal from CBS and when I came
back I called Mel and she told me come
to the store I was due she's admitting
the whole [ __ ] thing I mean it was
just mind-boggling how nice of a lady
she was she had the black husband David
David Davis always had those mints in
his pocket yeah I got always the bet on
baby to have it Kenya Manchus it was
just a weird I don't know what she was
to you and me she was like she went off
on you she went off on me you know it
was like she was like she would go off
on me for bad relationship choices cuz I
would always tell her what was going on
he's still bit you know you think she
would tell me some nasty things I should
be doing instead of trying to be
romantic it's funny how I have a picture
of her Maya on my clipboard it's like I
have a clipboard on the wall and I just
look at it whenever I see and I just
think I say she would call the house dog
and if I didn't pick up my mini old
answered answering machine pick up pick
up pick up hello I know you're there she
was saying [ __ ] and my girlfriend
would go how people do you hang out with
that's when I first started a Terry and
man who would call my house we leave the
store it - you went to the Santa Monica
you got a chicken burrito just talk that
so about quarter to three and then you
went home and a half hour later your
phone's ringing it's Bauer
and all since you gotta go that's a guy
calling me who phone sex and then she
would go get his phone sex guy and I'd
be sitting this Martin bloke and awesome
my phone would ring what's up
[ __ ] him he wanted me to stick a
broomstick up my [ __ ] like she would
say and you and I'd be coked-up Gabriel
I'd be five in the morning coke you've
talked about Maryland before that you
know people know that she's she used to
be a a phone sex operator back in the
day those nine seven six days in the
night well it was five four four 303 478
god rest her soul I'm not saying nothing
bad about I miss her dearly I couldn't
even imagine her around today like oh
wow I couldn't even imagine her around
tipping the scales at four hundred
eating on a podcast talking dirty [ __ ]
about people because by this time she
would have been [ __ ] God she would
have still been talking [ __ ] about
poetry God rest his soul
yeah she was not for the sensitive yeah
well you know it was weird that she was
a phone sex operator and she told me
that you character was Miko Miko I'm a
Japanese Japanese she was Mexican Miko
and something else and this huge smoke
every chica she sounds so way good a
little oh my god this is how she paid
the bills yes yes oh my god and I've
never gone on the road with them going
to the whole term where they had a
cooler fill the licorice yeah they were
like walking diabetes it was tremendous
it was tremendous it was like having a
mom but not really she was a Comley
[ __ ] check
was awesome she's been dead for 12 years
that's how long I've been clean she died
the week I decided to get clean so
that's some trying to save you
Jeff Valdez caught a beatin eight years
later I waited in the bushes like like
what's his name of the beginning the
[ __ ] what's his name of the beginning of
apocalypse now that moment he takes the
head of acid he's naked in his room
Charlie Sheen's father work oh I'm like
Martin Sheen remember he says right now
I'm in this room getting weaker while
Charlie's in the bush getting stronger
I was just Charlotte in the bush getting
stronger and I always knew I was a light
Valdez up for that night he broke me
like it didn't matter what else is going
on in my life like I didn't man I was
poor it didn't matter that I didn't have
a [ __ ] theatrical agent didn't man
that nobody wanted to sign me that none
of that [ __ ] man it you couldn't give me
a spot that dirty show at the festival I
never forgave him to that and how he
switched it up that week after he
humiliated me like four or five times
the following year he sent us down there
and he paid this woman Marilyn Marilyn
and then just because he sent me down
there didn't mean I forgave him I always
kept that in the back of my mind it was
always gonna be a smack to the face at
least I knew it was gonna be a smack to
the face so I let it whatever I picked
up the Longest Yard they called me they
try to run a scam by me first thing
called with a number I said go [ __ ]
yourself then they called back with the
number I asked for like that easy
like all of a sudden I was [ __ ] Bill
Cosby I'm the hottest act like just they
would they just weren't right something
wasn't right and then they did that last
festival where everybody bowed out of
and they did the theater Jeff Valdez did
the theater on Holly
Boulevard I was still living in
Hollywood he kept calling me going come
on come over and do this either it
doesn't pay anything but he's charging
fifty five miles of the door he's not
paying anything and I and I was over it
already
I was over the whole Latin scene that
that ship had [ __ ] sailed and went
like the whole whole whole thing had
gone it was broken and all of a sudden
the thing I [ __ ] hate the most
happened
a friend of mine guys so at the time I
know he was given her work
I mean they were doing that TV show
about her working with kids yeah this uh
was a short like CTV well yes he was
paying like 500 bucks I'm not mad at him
for that I was mad at him for what he
put us through because not only was I
heartbroken but Madelyn cried Marilyn
cried to me saying that the reason why
she didn't get it was good as she wasn't
pretty [ __ ] and I just never forgot that
night and I just knew he was gonna get
it and all of a sudden God forbid eight
years later Marilyn Martinez is dead I
get off the plane from New York haven't
done coke all weekend so it was four
days into wrestling with the no coke
thing I get back there's gonna be awake
my cat dies I make a [ __ ] promise
that I'm not gonna snort coke if the
other cat lives and all of a sudden we
have to go to church for Marilyn
Martinez and I parked the car I was
maybe 390 at the time and I was taking
kung fu' and Silverlake with some
[ __ ] karate when that was how joking
around and he came okay and I'll never
forget parking the car going in and
seeing Jeff Valdez by the church and my
blood pressure went up from 100 to 190
and I said hello I was called you and
there was drama
going on who was gonna pay for the
funeral balance husband couldn't afford
the funeral some people said they were
gonna pay for the funeral but if certain
people showed up they weren't gonna pay
for the funeral so David was all
stressed out I was living in a [ __ ]
apartment I could barely make seven
hundred miles a month rent I couldn't
help but I felt horrible so I knew all
this bad energy was going on so you know
me you know I'm headed and at that time
I had the drugs going on so I could I
can hit you with a dish I threw a bottle
at some guy at The Comedy Store I used
you know I was doing [ __ ] that junkies
do you know I'm saying I was doing
junkie [ __ ]
so I bowed out of that thing at The
Comedy Store that church thing was that
10 o'clock a.m. I saw Jeff there like
11:00 then my blood pressure started
going up I went home and I said I'm
gonna stay home and mind my business I
even took a sleeping pill I took a
sleeping pill so I wouldn't do coke it
would have been like the seventh day but
I would have been cleaned from coked and
I was already burning the [ __ ] up and
now my best friend dies somebody who
calls me every night and calls me
[ __ ] and all this [ __ ] and I go
[ __ ] this my friend my friend the man
was not my friend I'm walking she
started drinking and it was too [ __ ]
mine
call me up Moschino listen I'm gonna
tell you how to live your life she was
your friend if you don't go it's gonna
look bad and like you know what you're
absolutely right and I [ __ ] wet there
but I stopped I got $60 out of the ATM
at sunset and I wanted to deal his house
and I bought a grand Mike ultimate put
in my drug pocket and I know I'm gonna
go down there and I'm gonna [ __ ] do
whatever they were having like that you
were there at that story at the store we
had a talk you were there mmm okay so I
walked isn't a little bigger than naked
too right bleep you showed up no by that
time they had sent me home I was banned
from the building
it's [ __ ] like that and by the way I
didn't get
that [ __ ] she sure called me he told
her the truth and she got [ __ ] him I
didn't like him anyway he's a greasy
[ __ ] or something so I was like
whoo I risked that bullet I want to go
in there and make the turn now I'm
cleaning off coke for seven days I'm
pissed off about that I'm pissed off
because they offered me a movie and the
people said to me excuse me before you
accept the movie want you to think about
it because you know we know you have a
drug habit I was just about that I was
pissed about Marilyn I was pissed about
everything in my [ __ ] life wasn't
going the right way and I walked into
the Kamiya store main room and there's a
buffet for Marilyn's death there was a
line of food in the back that Corey
Cuomo had put together Freddy sodas one
life God rest his soul and who was eaten
the free food but Jeff Valdez that was
the ultimate insult where I come from I
knew I had to stab in the [ __ ] neck I
went in I don't even have time this just
elliptical I swear to God I went in and
I got like a Dewar's on the rocks and I
drank it and I walked and my blood
pressure my heart was pounding I didn't
know if I was gonna hit him and all
sudden they stop me and they go hey
we're gonna we're gonna start this dad
because this
57
I went home one day I swear to God about
a month ago I just went the white man
from Ibiza [ __ ] I didn't question maybe
I made a mistake I didn't know how I got
there about a week later again my answer
is a little birdy thing [ __ ] I go back
there's like a little [ __ ] will you
come out like a milk dud like oh wow so
yeah I got a little mug nuts like I'm
losing like people but if somebody gotta
wear a diaper I'm like two months away
from wearing a diaper
we'll have some fun [ __ ] you drive a
little bit and throw them out the window
you can't even do that now
no the cops are bringing in check your
23andme and also then you are at home
jerking off watching TV and the cops
come with your baggie with you when
you're [ __ ] me undies on and then I
listen we found your [ __ ] sperm in
here oh by the way you're not Mexican
ladies thank you for anything you want
to tell us what season date anything
they haven't given me any information
what's the name of this tour the name of
the tours beyond the fluffy [ __ ] it [ __ ]
it
god bless I'm fluffy it's been in
Holland I know you [ __ ] 20 years I've
seen a throw up in front of me I'm an
old man I'm 57 next Wednesday
Wow happy birthday Wow happy birth is
nice present for myself
[ __ ] Gabriel let's check them drawers
[ __ ] potato tacos they [ __ ] Joe my
wife's probably anymore even the other
kids who couldn't wait to get their
hands on thank you very much for coming
on guys let me jelly love you brother
all right don't forget you dirty
[ __ ] there an extra show in
Tempe on Thursday night 10:00
fifteen and on the 27th to 28th of
February I'll be a treasure island in
Las Vegas check the [ __ ] schedule to
228 before we leave like I said this is
brought to you by butcher box I am in
love with this that what's the best
night of the week steak night followed
by mama letting you get a little sniff a
little whiff listen to me this meat is
[ __ ] tremendous like I said they
vacuum seal it they deliver it right to
your door it's fresh whether you get the
salmon that the mistakes I mean they
sent ground beef everything was [ __ ]
first class with butcher box you get the
best quality steaks delivered right to
your door
butcher box the subscription service
that sends you nine to eleven pounds of
high-quality humanely raised meat every
month that's enough to cover you for 24
meals and butcher boxes affordable each
meal but breaks down to about six
dollars they ship it frozen in the
vacuum seal and of the rise in your door
fresh as a [ __ ] little monkey in the
morning Oh
you choose what you get you can
customize every order with healthy
high-quality meats like grass-fed beef
free grain range chicken heritage pork
and wild caught salmon the salmon was
[ __ ] to die for or pick one of the
curated collections on that butcher box
and do all the work for you right now
butcher box is a special officer what
we're gonna do is this we're gonna give
you free wings for a life of your
subscription today what I'm saying to
you not those little [ __ ] HIV wings
I'm talking about [ __ ] wings
that's three pounds of wings in every
box forever plus you get twenty bucks 20
bucks raw for your first box and free
shipping in the lower 48 do me a favor
check this out you're not gonna believe
it go to butcher box.com slash Church
use promo code Church at checkout
that's butcher box.com slash Church or
use promo code Church and check out
butcher box the way meat should be I
don't want to thank my man Gabriel Asus
for coming down and I want to thank the
Flying Jew or aka the Christ killer but
most importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for support me I'll see
you guys at Tempe if not I'll see you
next [ __ ] Tuesday
ready to go tip-top Magoo stay black
have a good week and a great weekend I
love you [ __ ] kick this [ __ ]
mule bleah